à montréal depuis 2014 il ya un cycliste
qui est mort et cinq autres qui ont été
grièvement blessés parce qu'un véhicule
les a dépassées sans respecter une
distance sécuritaire
pourtant la loi est claire un
automobiliste même chauffeur d'autobus
doit respecter une distance variant de 1
à 1 mètre et demi selon la limite de
vitesse quand il dépasse un vélo parce
que oui les cyclistes au droit
d'utiliser la voie publique mais est ce
une loi que les policiers peuvent faire
respecter
[Musique]
l'an dernier il ya eu peu de constats
d'infraction 18 à montréal deux à
longueuil et une douzaine d'années par
la sûreté du québec dans l'ensemble du
territoire québécois
il ya même des policiers qui ont dit
publiquement qu appliquer cette loi
pouvait s'avérer difficile d'abord parce
que les dépassements se déroulent
souvent rapidement et que c'est
compliqué d'évaluer avec certitude la
distance entre un vélo et un véhicule
lors d'un dépassement
pourtant il existe des outils depuis
l'automne dernier les policiers à vélo
de la ville d'ottawa sont équipés de
radar qui mesure à quelques centimètres
près la distance entre le vélo du
policier et le véhicule qu'ils dépassent
ce système qui a été développée aux
états unis compte environ 1500 dollars
américains en plus d'ottawa ce détecteur
de distance et également à l'essai dans
quelques municipalités ontariennes
[Musique]